i'm leaving soon how do i look
good actually well you don't have to
sound surprised well
it's nice you want to look good for
brenda sparks
what are you looking for
deck of cards why are you gonna play
with the kids of course not well i
invited the guy's over for poker
you're supposed to be babysitting they
don't want me around they're gonna be
watching tv but do you really need to be
gambling i thought you were trying to be
fun tonight
i am well this seems like a good place
to start
you have a nice time with your friends
thank you
but so help me if the house smells like
cigars when i get home you will not hear
the end of it it's your first day being
fun you keep trying
how come it's taken us so long to hang
out well
my husband never left me before
we can joke about it
good cause that's gonna make this night
way easier
here we go
is that three beers i see it's girls
night out i said i was going to show you
a good time all right then party girl
give us a toast oh um
well uh
bless these beers
and the bartender who poured them
seriously i thought it was good okay i
i'll handle this
to friends
and to brenda's crap husband who made
this night possible mom it's okay she
said we could joke about it
i think he cared more about those stupid
chickens that he didn't meet oh that's
not true he took them when he left okay
that's a tough one give me a sec why are
we talking about this we should be
having fun
actually it feels good to get it off my
chest well let's get into it what
happened
if there's another woman she's a [ __ ]
and you're way prettier no
although sometimes i wish there was
then i'd have someone to be mad at other
than myself
and here i thought this one was going to
be the sad sec mom that is enough oh
there's my little killjoy
[Laughter]
you ready to start dating again
i think i need some time
well if you change your mind there's a
gentleman over here at the bar who would
like us to see his butt crack
so
then was there no big blow up when he
left not really
well
what happened
let's see
we used to be happy
little by little we weren't
then there was bickering
then there was silence and
then
it was over
poppy
all couples bigger right
you worried about you and george
of course i'm sure you guys will be fine
and if it doesn't work out i'll be happy
to introduce you to butt crack bob over
here
virus heartbreak can also spread
once it does it's hard to contain
[Music]
in some cases you can try to reboot and
start over
but it makes you appreciate those early
days
when your hard drive was clean
[Music]
and the world was full of possibility
[Music]